difference the 1971 winner of the Nobel
Prize in Economics Simon Kuznets stated
this based on their economic performance
there were four kinds of countries
developed countries developing countries
Argentina and Japan
folks both Argentina and Japan are
currently facing many economic problems
but the steps taken to reach their
present situations they couldn't have
been more different their paths have
been so different that we want to take a
closer look so what steps of Argentina
and Japan followed to get to where they
are today how are they similar how are
they different
how did Japan a rocky islands without
natural resources managed to progress
while Argentina with its vast territory
and the huge amounts of resources
struggles to keep its state out of
chronic crisis well we're going to tell
you all about it in today's video pads
awesome country's doomed to success and
others to failure our natural resources
a blessing or a punishments well let's
get back to the first half of the 20th
century how is Argentina's economy
compared to Japan's 100 years ago
folks in the early 1900's the
differences between Argentina and Japan
were extreme their situations were the
opposite of what they are today
Argentina was a much more developed
country than Japan it said natural
resources and educated population and
open trade with the rest of the world
was a world power it was a country that
was wealthier than the United States
meanwhile Japan was a much less
developed country that had very
traditional institutions
if we had been asked for a forecast at
that time we've probably all picked
Argentina to go on and become the
richest country on the planet while
Japan would struggle for subsistence
bradford differentiated these two
countries the most was their natural
resources while the argentine territory
is full of natural resources mother
nature was not so generous with the
japanese japan is a small chain of rocky
islands with very little habitable
territory it's exposed to all kinds of
natural disasters and it has very few
natural resources
as if that weren't enough in 1945 World
War two ended with the detonation of two
nuclear bombs over Japan the only ones
that have ever been used in war
from that moment on the country it was
devastated city's infrastructure and
industry worked to a large extent
destroyed over three million Japanese
especially young Japanese lost their
lives and more than ten million soldiers
returned home from the front with no
jobs
in 1945 nobody absolutely nobody would
have bet on Japan's future
but practically all of us would have bet
on Argentina's future you see at the
beginning of the 20th century Argentina
was also something of a beacon in Latin
America his economy was among the top
ten in the world had the highest social
development levels it's rail network was
growing rapidly education system was
highly advanced and the country held a
large share in the global capital market
on some examples well in those years
Argentina is one of the main recipients
of direct European investments it was
one of the largest primary goods
exporters in the world and the second
most popular destination for immigrants
from the old continent yes at this time
German spaniards and italians migrated
on masse to argentina in other words
we're talking about a country that saw
the united states as its equal that
explains why at the time when US aires
was on the list with the london new york
or any other major city in the world and
on top of that it managed to stay after
the second world war saving many lives
and many dollars so don't tell me you
would have a better large antenna about
my last scent you would hold on just a
second because things soon began to
change take a look at this chart at the
beginning of the 20th century
Argentina's GDP per capita was three
times higher than that of Japan this gap
remained until the end of the Second
World War however from the 50s onwards
there was a significant change suddenly
Japan began catching up at full speed so
much so that by the end of the 1960's
the Land of the Rising Sun had already
surpassed Argentina since then the gap
has only increased
so the question is what happens what did
Japan do that Argentina didn't well
listen up
Japan versus Argentina
Argentina's territory is seven times
larger than that of Japan while
Argentina's population is only about one
third of Japan's
the density isn't the only difference
between the two countries as we've
already mentioned the Argentine
territory went compared to Japan is much
more fertile and also boasts a lot of
natural resources of all kinds oil
natural gas gold silver copper coal iron
lithium Argentina still has practically
everything
Argentina is ranked sixth on the list of
countries with the largest amount of
mining resources in the world
of course being blessed with natural
conditions doesn't make production any
simpler during the 19th century
argentinian investors poured a lot of
money into machinery and infrastructure
so that the country could become one of
the largest food producers in the world
by the beginning of the 20th century in
the 1800's Argentina's political system
and institutions such as property rights
or freedom of trade encouraged investors
to invest their money in the country
meanwhile during the second half of the
19th century Japan made similar changes
we've already talked about this on
visual politic and I'm gonna leave a
link to that video in the description
below this was known as the Meiji
Restoration
however as changes were slower in the
natural conditions harder the results by
the beginning of the 20th century was
not so impressive and then well along
came the Second World War
the ends of this conflicts left Japan a
ruined broken and devastated country
while Argentina which although it had
suffered during the crisis of 1929 was
still a prosperous country there was
even a creditor for England and many
other nations that had participated in
the war so with a solid financial
position many natural resources are well
educated population no threat of war or
conflicts at growing middle class and a
huge global demand for food the
prospects for the country of tango
couldn't have really been better but
let's go back to the main question at
what point did Argentina and Japan begin
to take such a difference in divergent
paths you see after the Second World War
Japan in one way or another began to
slowly assimilate and copy many of the
elements that had made the United States
prosper
this had a lot to do with the u.s.
occupation under the command of General
Douglas MacArthur leader of the supreme
command of the Allied forces these
occupation forces aims to demilitarize
and democratize Japanese society to do
so the Constitution was rewritten and
many of the us's institutions were
copied such as the elimination of the
power and of the government size the
protection of private property and the
freedom of business commerce in short
Japan opened itself up to the world
meanwhile Argentina did the opposite in
February 1946 juan domingo perón became
the country's president with him came a
real model change for the South American
country suddenly the state began to
increase its size and its influence on
the economy and small aspects of
Argentinian society a lot of countries
were nationalized especially those
dedicated transport energy in
communications tons of the government's
controlled and a lot of restrictions on
foreign trade were approved in addition
there were a lot of regulations of all
kinds in practice parent transformed
Argentina into a kind of army rules by
the orders of its presidents
to carry out his plans the liberal
constitution of 1853 was replaced by a
paradise one in 1949 in the first 10
years of perón's leadership that
government distortions of the state's
economic activity was so great that
Argentinians eventually had to eat black
bread and ration their meat consumption
this is not because of a vegan VAD or
anything like that but because of
scarcity Argentinian producers opted to
stop producing rather than comply with
the price controls or the exchange rates
that were established by the government
and on top of all of that prawns exit
from power didn't really cause any
change yes some economic freedoms were
reintroduced and some controls were
suppressed but the states wait its size
and its interference in the country's
economic activity did not received
public spending high taxes and inflation
had come to stay
folks the changes prompt set in motion
in Argentina became definitive and to
this we understand the political
instability caused by eight secession of
military coos these are a crisis that
happens in Argentina over and over again
every five to ten years the results as
you all know is that today Argentina is
no longer one of the ten richest
countries in the world it's not even in
the top 25 it's not even in the top 50
according to data from the International
Monetary Fund's and taking price
differences into accounts in purchasing
power parity terms Argentina ranks 62nd
and the countries with the highest GDP
per capita that is it's at the same
level as countries like Iran Belarus or
Gabon
and everything indicates that after the
last crisis it's gonna fall even further
down the list today 32% of Argentinians
that's one in three live in poverty
Argentina is one of the few countries in
the world where poverty is increasing
instead of decreasing anyway folks
that's how Japan and Argentina revolved
in several videos on this channel we've
seen in detail how Argentina and Japan
became what they are today but now the
question is can we extract some key
points from comparing these two well I
believe we can check this out
the key points let's see by comparing
Argentina and Japan we can extract three
main ideas that I think we should always
take into account the first and let's
make this really clear is it a country
isn't rich or poor because of its
natural resources or its size it's
useless to have huge amounts of
resources if they aren't properly
exploited in fact Japan proves that a
country can be very rich without having
natural resources or a lot of territory
what matters folks what really makes a
difference in wealth generation is a
country's level of capital investment
and work innovation and productivity are
much much more important than Natural
Resources the second idea is that a
country that reaches a high level of
development and prosperity is not
guaranteed to sustain that level
indefinitely
well that doesn't exist per se it has to
be created continually and its creation
needs to adapt to the changes that occur
in the world otherwise you could have a
similar experience to Argentina which
went from being the richest country on
earth to 60 second place and falling of
course such a decline in fortune is bad
for everyone especially for the most
disadvantaged members of the population
punishing a productive economy is always
a bad idea the third idea is that wealth
isn't achieved by government spending
like crazy public spending can only be
financed through three methods more
taxes more public debt or running the
bill printing machine that is increasing
inflation all three methods cause
nothing but crisis and poverty you have
to be very clear about where public
spending will end if you want a country
to prosper and if you don't believe me
you can see another good example of this
in Venezuela anyway folks this was a
comparison comparing how Argentina and
Japan evolved into what we can learn
from them I really hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit that like button if
you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos also don't forget
to check out our friends the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine also
this channel is possible because of
patreon hands our patrons on that
platform please consider joining them
and supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always I'll see you in the next video